si vous êtes submergé par la par la
masse d'eau c'est ça c'est ça et ma
première pensée ça a été
tu vas pas souffrir
bonsoir Philippe Gilbert vous êtes
informaticien vous vivez à
Lussac-Saint-Emilion en Gironde mais
depuis de nombreuses années vous passez
plusieurs semaines par an au Sri Lanka
où vous étiez le jour du tsunami
vous racontez cette aventure dans un
livre qui s'appelle les larmes de Ceylan
aux éditions des équateurs alors le 26
décembre 2004 vous êtes donc dans le sud
de l'île de celand dans un bungalow vous
avez fait construire dans un village de
pêcheurs près de tango vous y vivez
quatre mois par an il est amoureux de
ces langues vous êtes tombé amoureux de
Ceylan vous avez des amis Sri Lankais
notamment MH parce qu'il préfère qu'on
appelle comme ça et Kamina sa femme ils
ont une petite fille au 110 qui a 7 ans
qui joue avec votre petite fille
Juliette qui a 4 ans voilà en effet
Delphine votre fille et Jérôme votre
gendre sont venus passer des vacances à
Ceylan ce matin-là votre gendre vous
propose d'aller pêcher mais avant il va
faire le marché à tango avec votre fille
les 9 heures vous surveillez les les
deux fillettes et le dessine
et là une touriste qui loue une chambre
chez MH votre voisin Sri Lankais et
surprise par une vague que vous
qualifiez de téméraire dans votre livre
il se réfugie dans le jardin et vous
l'aidez à ce moment-là vous avez le
sentiment qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'extraordinaire où vous trouvez ça
presque naturel en ce moment là je
trouve ça tout à fait naturel je suis
habitué à voir la vague de temps en
temps venir lécher le bord du bungalow
donc non non je suis pas du tout surpris
alors l'eau passe la clôture du petit
jardinier vous réagissez pas plus à ce
moment-là vous rentrez dans votre
bungalow pour pas être mouillé et là le
flot d'eau s'engouffre dans la pièce en
fraquant son tout sur son passage dire
que là la porte d'entrée vole en éclat
quoi là vous comprenez qu'il se passe
quelque chose de oui là à ce moment-là
je prends en conscience même si j'ai pas
conscience totale de ce qui va
réellement se passer quelques secondes
après là je commence à
comprendre que ça n'est pas normal en
fait voilà vous comprenez qu'il se passe
quelque chose il y a un deuxième flot
qui est torrentiel dites-vous vous avez
de l'eau jusqu'au cou et vous vous
sortez du du bungalow où vous êtes
réfugiés et dehors la vision est
absolument terrifiante il y a une vague
monstrueuse et vous avez cette image
vous dites j'ai l'impression d'être
comme un Égyptien dans le film Les dix
commandements au moment où la mer Rouge
se referme quoi si vous êtes submergé
par la masse d'eau c'est ça c'est ça et
ma première pensée ça a été
tu vas pas souffrir ouais quand vous
voyez un truc comme ça là vous pensez
que vous allez mourir à ce moment-là ah
oui oui j'en suis tout à fait persuadé
je suis simplement rassuré à l'idée que
ça va ça va ça va aller très vite et que
je souffrirai pas donc ah oui oui c'est
pour moi là je suis mort
heureusement voilà vous êtes transporté
à 30 mètres de chez vous heureusement
vous accrochez un cocotier et là vous
vous prenez comme ça quoi comme une
espèce de bouée de sauvetage c'est le
cas de le dire et vous laissez passer la
vague et vous vous parvenez à continuer
à respirer donc à survivre
tout ça se passe très très vite vraiment
très très vite et après une fois que
vous êtes accroché
c'est un terminal faut que ça cesse faut
que ça cesse et puis ça cesse voilà et
aux enfants étaient en sécurité la
chance de ma fille et de mon gendre
c'est qu'ils étaient partis au marché ce
jour-là une heure tout à fait
inhabituelle d'habitude il part au
marché beaucoup plus tard que ça là ils
sont partis et d'habitude ils emmènent
Juliette avec eux et là je leur dis vu
l'heure laisser Juliette elle est avec
70 tranquille laissé je vais les garder
quoi
vous demandez donc ou sans au Sandy la
fille de vos amis shri-lanqués et
Juliette oui il faut savoir que là vu le
spectacle auquel j'ai assisté je n'ai
pas le moindre doute sur le fait que
Juliette et au samedi soir soit morte
ne peuvent pas avoir je vois la chambre
où elles étaient je vois il y a un
bateau dedans il y a enfin c'est donc je
n'ai plus de doute là-dessus maintenant
il me reste un truc terrible à faire
c'est d'annoncer ça m'a fait de revenir
si vous voulez
d'aller vers eux et de d'affronter le
regard de ma fille qui va me voir
arriver moi vivant tout seul sans sa
fille
là effectivement vous les retrouvez sur
le marché de tango ils sont même pas
mouillés évidemment puisque c'est à des
kilomètres de là vous dites jamais je
n'oublierai le cri de Delphine un cri
d'aimant insoutenable
oui
à rien d'autre à rajouter
c'est ça ça m'a marqué pour le restant
de mes jours c'est
alors ensuite vous allez dans un hôtel
qui est situé à 7 km de tango sur les
hauteurs un hôtel qui s'appelle Eva
Lanka et là vous êtes choqué parce qu'en
fait les touristes évidemment ils savent
pas ce qui s'est passé donc il profite
de la journée de vacances comme si de
rien n'était et nous on arrive là enfin
encore que ma fille et mon gendre
étaient correctement habillée mais en ce
qui me concerne j'étais en loc en sang
ça fait un drôle d'effet de voir qu'il y
a des gens qui ont pu ne pas se rendre
compte du tout de ce qui s'était passé
alors il y a une personne qui concernait
quand même c'est laine de Wingles de LCI
qui qui là avec son compagnon Emmanuel
Carrère l'écrivain oui elle vous parle
et vous témoignez sur LCI de ce qui
s'est passé en fait ce jour-là oui et ça
ça a été le départ de tous ça a été
si j'ose utiliser des mots comme ça dans
notre situation c'était une chance inouï
une chance inouïe parce que si vous
voulez il est évident qu'on aurait de
toute façon aider les les très proches
amis de ne serait-ce que de cette sortie
de ça mais là le fait que j'ai été par
chance le premier à témoigner
ça tout de suite amener les médias vers
nous quand on est rentré en France
bon c'est pas trop trop mon style de
jouer avec ça mais là je crois que
j'avais pas le choix il aurait fallu que
je sois très con pour ne pas jouer à ce
jeu donc on a laissé les articles
paraître dans Paris Match
on a même été jusqu'à accepter que une
photo de Julie était au samedi soit
diffusée c'était pas de gaieté de coeur
mais je crois que c'était le seul moyen
pour qu'on récolte la somme maximale
nous permettant d'aider non plus une
deux trois familles mais quelques 50 ou
100 familles puisque c'était notre
objectif à partir de ce moment-là alors
ce que vous découvrez à ce moment là
c'est qu'il est impossible de rapatrier
le corps de votre petite fille Juliette
pour la faire incinérer en France c'est
c'est purement interdit il faut le faire
au Sri Lanka et un jour vous irez jeter
les cendres de Juliette dans un jardin
botanique à Candy près d'un massif de
bougainvillier alors vous vivez depuis
avec une espèce de culpabilité
vous vous dites évidemment j'aurais pu
la sauver alors il y a une chose qu'on
prend pas bien dans le livre quand la
vague arrive est-ce qu'elle est sur la
terrasse de votre bungalow sur la
terrasse du bungalow de valoisin MH ou
est-ce qu'elle est dans une pièce de la
maison de votre voisin est une dizaine
de mètres derrière moi même pas enfin
admettons une dizaine de mètres derrière
moi dans une dans une dans une chambre
une chambre d'hôtes quoi si vous voulez
elle joue avec sa petite copine le
samedi il y a 10 mètres vous l'aviez
sous les yeux à ce moment-là j'avais
aucune raison à ce moment-là avant que
la vague arrive de les surveiller de
très près c'est un endroit très très
très en sécurité c'est c'est vraiment
c'est un véritable paradis donc il y a
aucune raison de les surveiller de plus
près que d'habitude par contre après
entre le moment où la vague m'est arrivé
dessus et le moment je me suis retrouvé
30 mètres plus loin avec le accroche
comme un con à ce cocotier je peux même
pas dire que j'ai pensé à ce moment-là
je peux le temps j'ai pas eu j'ai pensé
à rien strictement rien
voilà alors là vous commencez avec votre
gendre Jérôme à échafauder une
association pour aider les habitants de
ce petit village de pêcheurs vous
inventez ce qu'on appelle le kit de
nécessité alors c'est quoi exactement
vous savez ça consiste
d'abord on s'improvise on n'a jamais
fait humanitaire donc vous arrivez avec
un track pas possible
en vous demandant si vous allez être à
la hauteur parce que c'est quand même
vous avez pas le droit de vous planter
et puis vous allez à l'essentiel vous
distribuez des feuilles de papier dans
le village et vous dites aux gens en
fait vous vous prenez le tu as besoin de
quoi prenez la commande quoi tu as
besoin de quoi on n'est pas les blancs
Sauveur venant à la rescousse non non là
on se fait tout petit de quoi tu as
besoin et on s'aperçoit ça va très vite
c'est en quelques jours les besoins sont
toujours les mêmes un lit un matelas et
ça ça a pris une importance terrible
après vous verrez un moustiquaire des
ustensiles de cuisine
il y a des besoins enfin c'est vraiment
élémentaires
leur rendre leur dignité en fait voilà
attention la plupart des familles n'ont
plus de toi non plus de mais au-delà du
fait qu'elle n'est plus de toi et plus
de maison elle mange dans des feuilles
de journaux et les enfants dorment par
terre sur les ruines des maisons et ça
je l'ai vu de mes yeux vu là vous vous
dites c'est urgence alors vous cherchez
pas à vous organiser
vous partez au quart de tour vous foncez
alors vous faites des bêtises vous vous
mettez 4 jours à équiper 10 familles
parce que vous pensez qu'il faut faire
le tour des commerçants etc etc puis
après on devient un petit peu moins bête
on se dit bah on va s'organiser on va
distribuer des tickets aux gens ils vont
aller eux-mêmes dans les boutiques
tout ça se met en or il faut reconnaître
aussi qu'on a la faire un peuple qui n'a
pas du tout la mentalité des peuples
occidentaux on est sur des gens qui sont
face à ce malheur d'une dignité déjà
absolue
extrêmement réservé pas il y a pas de
panique il y a aucune scène de panique
alors que il faut pas oublier c'est que
là on est au bout du bout de la première
semaine on sait qu'on va avoir 700
familles à équiper on a là ça y est on
le sait on va même pouvoir on va on a
mis une frontière si vous voulez
medakétia mais c'est horrible déjà ça
cette frontière bah toi tu es de l'autre
côté de la route tu tu rentres pas dans
le c'est c'est voilà vous vous mettez au
boulot avec Jérôme pour essayer de les
aider et en revanche pas de traces d'ONG
vous dites où sont les dons où sont les
20 tonnes de médicaments amenés dans cet
Airbus 310 ça a coûté 300.000 euros pour
la pour acheminer les dons vous vous
voyez rien vous voyez des 4x4
flamboyants dites-vous des 4 4 9 de la
Croix-Rouge et vous dites qu'une de ces
voitures vous permettrait à vous enfin
en tous les cas aux gens du Sri Lanka de
reconstruire sans maison
dans l'avion on se on s'inquiétait de
savoir comment on allait pouvoir nous
tout peut-il
s'entendre avec toutes ces ONG sur place
parce que comme vous on a entendu que il
y avait des dons faramineux que toutes
les ONG étaient là-bas que c'est dit
comment on va trouver notre place là
à ça pas été difficile on était tout
seul on était tout seul quand je suis
arrivé au début février on était tout
seul quand je compte mon gendre est
parti fin avril absolument personne
c'est incroyable parce que la France a
envoyé 190 millions d'euros alors il
paraît que l'argent est placé dans les
sicaves monétaires c'est un véritable
scandale déjà genre quand je lis moi
dans Le Parisien c'est Monsieur Mattei
lui-même qui le dit que il a reçu le
patron de la Croix Rouge après avoir été
patron de la canicule je tiens voilà il
100 millions de dons et à aujourd'hui
ils ont dépensé sept il y a quand même
quelque chose absolument obscène à
détourner de cette façon l'argent que
les gens ont donné pour le Sri Lanka la
Thaïlande le c'est absolument scandaleux
oui il y a 7 % des sommes qui ont été
données au sri lankais le reste ils
l'ont pas vu voilà moi je ne remets pas
en cause le le la bonne foi de ces gens
je dis c'est de l'appétit mais en même
temps c'est tout à fait scandaleux donc
il faut demander des comptes à la
Croix-Rouge bien sûr et ben on va
appeler le docteur Robert Sebag
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
administrateur national la Croix-Rouge
votre fonction en fait c'est de faire la
somme des dons reçus de savoir comment
l'argent est
et dépenser les missions sur le terrain
c'est moins votre truc en face quand
même vous qui gérez le pognon j'en ai
fait une voilà alors où est l'argent où
est le pognon alors ce que ce que je
peux vous assurer il y a une partie de
l'argent qui a été dépensé et il y a il
y a une programmation on a signé on sent
en ce qui vous concerne d'accord il y a
70 millions vous dites combien 7
/ 100 7 sur 100 millions voilà alors où
sont les 93 millions il y a 70 millions
d'euros qui sont engagés aujourd'hui il
y a mille maisons deux hôpitaux Sri
Lanka en Indonésie en approvisionnement
en eau qui se fait dans la région
d'empara dans la région dans la région
de Galles vous le savez il faut des
bureaux il faut une logistique en
Indonésie on a pu plus plus de 50
personnes qui sont sur place il y a eu
le tremblement de terre sur lilias on a
été tout de suite là on a remis 10
litres d'eau par personne et par jour
160 ml d'eau à filtrer il fallait
transporter le matériel alors l'argent
il est pas dépensé en immédiat il est
pas dépensé comme ça l'argent et
pourquoi mais mais pourquoi vous
il vous faut des récipients d'air il
faut des gens de confiance vous pouvez
pas distribuer l'argent à n'importe qui
vous connaissez ce pays comme un enfant
que Philippe Gilbert mais pourquoi
est-ce que les braves pêcheurs qui ont
eu tout détruit on leur dit pas à chacun
on vous donne je sais pas moi 10000
dollars
pour acheter un bateau pour acheter on
est en train ce qu'on a jamais fait si
vous voulez d'avoir des partenaires
locaux des associations alors vérifie
qu'elles sont non mais
c'est c'est comme ça c'est bien parce
que votre discours au moins il est
honnête vous vous êtes en train de faire
un constat d'échec et enfin c'est
incroyable si je retourne je vais
retourner au mois de juillet au Sri
Lanka à côté de medakhetti
à manger dans des feuilles de journaux
alors 70 millions d'euros excusez-moi
docteur
attendez il n'est pas question il n'est
pas question de mettre ici en doute
l'efficacité et là et là et de la
Croix-Rouge c'est pas du tout notre
propos efficacité un peu quand même
l'efficacité comme dans tous les cas où
j'ai fait ses preuves depuis plus d'un
siècle bon ce que je veux dire ce que je
veux dire
ce que je veux dire simplement
Gilbert il dit voilà il dit moi je vais
retourner parce que c'est un amoureux de
silence c'est plus qu'un touriste c'est
un mec qui a construit une baraque
là-bas Gilbert bon donc il va aller
là-bas il va voir ces gens qui vont
continuer à bouffer dans des dans la
comédie dans des journaux à dormir sur
des ruines alors que vous vous avez je
sais pas des millions et des millions
d'euros sur des placés en SICAV
monétaire c'est ça qui concerne sur un
sujet pareil vraiment je veux pas pour
les Mickey surtout pas avec vous ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'on a repéré
un certain nombre d'associations locales
vous-même je vous le dis je le dis je le
dis devant tout le monde je veux dire
nous sommes tout à fait prêts sur votre
association parce que vous êtes
quelqu'un de confiance de votre village
vous avez vécu vous avez construit à
financer un projet je le dis c'est pas
c'est pas le scoop que je veux dire
prudent vous avez raison c'est important
mais c'est très très long vous êtes
submergé excusez-moi des mauvais jeux de
mots par la bureaucratie quoi la bureau
local aussi la bureaucratie locale faire
des virements d'argent locaux avoir les
dédouanements vous savez que même sur
des médicaments des des des des
filtresurs d'eau on doit à la douane on
doit payer un certain nombre de taxes
tout est contrôlé vous pouvez pas russe
pour une fois face à une catastrophe
comme celle-ci vous envoyez des équipes
comme la nôtre et des petites équipes de
rien du tout vous savez ce que je disais
moi les gens quand vous allez arriver à
l'aéroport vous allez vous allez pas
dire que vous êtes une vous allez dire
vous êtes touristes ça nous permettait
de rentrer tranquillement dans le pays
si jamais vous disiez ONG il vous
bloquait et vous restiez 15 jours à
Colombo et nous on passait comme
touriste on a ouvert un compte en banque
tout de suite là-bas on fait on faisait
virer l'argent là-bas
limite avec tout l'argent
1000 roupies par jour à chaque Sri
Lankais qui nous demande c'est décevant
je vais vous dire nous on a fait partie
les gens qui ont donné
rapidement et quand on voit que ils sont
toujours mal secourus
quand on est le village
on se demande toujours on va le pognon
il a la Croix-Rouge tout le monde a
confiance justement je vous il faut
aussi juger les programmes qu'ils ont
fait qui ont lieu aujourd'hui au Sri
Lanka vous êtes pas tomber sur les
villages mais je le dis et je le répète
votre association mais non écoutez vous
connaissez comme moi le Sri Lanka la
côte est énorme je veux dire vous pouvez
pas remettre en question on va
construire mille maisons on va
construire 300 hospitaliers il y a 25
personnes non mais une maison
on est aussi en Indonésie on est aussi
un nombre de pays où il y a eu personne
en Somalie parce que la Somalie a été
touché on en a pas parlé non mais ce qui
est urgence de lit des matelas c'est des
moustiquaires
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas déverser
vous pouvez pas déverser sur un pays 25
millions d'euros comme ça tout d'un coup
donc tout l'argent je peux vous assurer
de la charge
l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé tous les
intérêts sont reversés au programmatique
vous savez très bien que les périodes de
reconstruction ça va durer longtemps
encore
le but au bout du genou
de terre en Iran il y a aujourd'hui
encore des des
choses
organisations la Croix-Rouge française
on a pas eu on a eu beaucoup moins
d'argent que le tsunami à être présent
sur bam aujourd'hui à monter un certain
nombre de programmes je vous dis c'est
pas on vous connaît
il y a des volontaires c'est pas un
problème d'organisation
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi on a
aussi des comptes à rendre les gens
accepterais mais je suis d'accord mais
quand vous avez des partenaires comme
Monsieur on est tout à fait prêt je le
redis à aider spécifiquement son village
mais c'est pas seulement
j'avais une vision d'ensemble plus plus
bien sûr si concrète
bien vous êtes sincèrement
mais c'est pas ça c'est une réponse
de village et vous pour avoir des
témoins de village sous prétexte
monsieur ici
[Musique]
tout le monde c'est tout on pourrait on
pourrait avoir ici en face des
villageois dans lesquels nous sommes
présents on a on a fait des milliers des
milliers j'espère qu'il vous dirai
certaines organisations
qu'est-ce que vous parce que c'est ça
qui est important vous vous habitez
là-bas vous y allez plusieurs mois par
an vous êtes encore une fois vraiment je
suis dans le quai d'esprit qu'est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je pense qu'il faut
faire au moins je crois que je viens de
m'exprimer suffisamment sur le sujet je
vais tout simplement il faut que
l'argent qui aujourd'hui dort dans des
banques soit utilisé d'une façon d'une
autre alors c'est comme le dit fort
justement Laurent Ruquier c'est par
exemple payer chômeur en France et tant
pis si on fait du poujadisme parce que
là il y a des exigences en plus bon ou
tout simplement le le distribuer il y en
a pas besoin d'autant que vous en avez
des petites associations comme nous qui
vont au moins essayer de faire
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire de ramener très
vite ces villages à Lille parce que
quand vous dites mon village votre
village je peux vous assurer que j'ai
fait la route de Colombo à je sais où
vous étiez
que vous étiez plutôt sur la côte est
d'accord bien voilà voilà mais toute la
côte qui est là je peux vous dire que
les gens n'ont pas été aidés du tout
c'est-à-dire toute la côte entre Colombo
est en galle et on demande totale n'a
pas été aidé du tout par exemple ça pas
été non c'est qui ce qui a été fait non
c'est dans ces villes c'est la plupart
du temps on a travaillé sur le plan
hôpitaux
voilà là il y a eu beaucoup de choses de
fait donc ça je remets pas ça en
question mais c'est pas parce qu'on
construit un hôpital qu'il faut laisser
les gens dans la merde au bord de au
bord de l'eau vous voyez bon voilà et
surtout ce qui me choque c'est que c'est
des sommes faramineuses dont on entend
parler alors que nous avec 100000 euros
alors là c'est une goutte d'eau on a
redonné à 700 familles la dignité
élémentaire dont ils avaient besoin
voilà merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu